JAMIE ROSENBERG: Good
morning, everyone.
And wow.
If you could stand here and
look out at this, what a sight.
And what an amazing thing
to have all of you show up
and to spend this time
with us here today.
We have a fantastic
day lined up for you,
lots to update you about.
But also, this is a time
for us to get together, meet
each other, share ideas,
and have a bit of fun.
We are a community,
after all, and it's
the spirit of community that
I've come to look forward to
with these playtime events.
We did our first play time
event about four years
ago back in California.
Since then, we've taken
this on the road--
32 events in 14 countries
all over the world.
It's been a great
opportunity to connect
with our developers in many,
many markets around the world.
And I'm very pleased to say that
today, with you here in Berlin,
this is our biggest
Playtime event ever.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We know that you're
all busy people.
A lot of you
traveled to be here,
took time out of your
regular routines.
We're so grateful to be able
to spend this time with you
because we really all are on
an amazing journey together.
Tomorrow, actually, is
the ninth anniversary
of the first launch of the
very first Android smartphone.
Extra credit for any of you
who know what phone that was
and where it launched.
No fair using Google
for that, by the way.
Nine years.
That means that everything
about this world of smartphones
as we know it has happened
in less than 10 years.
This Android community
that we have that
now reaches more than 2 billion
devices all over the world
is less than 10 years old.
It's amazing to think
about the innovation that's
happened during that time--
how networks have
gotten faster, how
devices have become
these powerful computers
in our pockets, and how screens
on your wrist and in your car
and in your home have
gotten smart and connected.
And we've been
blown away with each
of these waves of innovation.
We've been blown
away by the work
that you all have done to
bring these devices to life.
And Google Play itself is
just over five years old.
And that's amazing
to think about.
We're now delivering more than
8 billion installs every month
on Play, reaching users
all over the world.
These are apps that entertain us
and educate us, inform us, keep
us healthy, help us get
things done in our lives.
And we take very seriously
the responsibility
to make Android and Play
a rewarding platform
for all of you.
Here in the EMEA region,
we have users of all types.
We have very tech-forward
power users, probably
like a lot of us in this room.
We have families who
use their smartphones
to stay connected
with each other
and share their experiences.
And we have users who are
being introduced to smartphones
and computing for the very
first time in countries
where the infrastructure
and networks can barely
support them.
Our job as a platform
is to help you
build the products
you want to build,
reach the audiences
who want to reach,
sometimes reach audiences
you didn't even know you had.
We take that job very seriously.
We're investing heavily
in tools to help
you build apps on Android,
distribute them in Google Play.
We're investing in one of the
largest billing and payment
platforms on the planet.
And we're constantly
looking for ways
to apply Google's technology
to the consumer experience
on Play.
For example, we've
matched our human curation
with Google machine
learning technology
to help match the right
app to the right user
in the right context.
And in some of these
cases, these investments
are happening right
here in Europe.
For example, our team that
builds the Play Console, which
I know many of you use, and
our Play Publishing Tools
is based in London.
And of course, our
partnership teams
and our support teams
that work with you
are based here in the region.
And we have teams that work with
mobile operators and Android
device manufacturers
in the region
to complete the picture
of our ecosystem.
Thanks to those
teams, by the way,
we're now connected
with 90 mobile carriers
in 38 countries in
EMEA for billing,
which means that more than 400
million users in the region
can pay for their
purchases on Google Play
through their
mobile phone build.
It's really valuable to
have these teams here
to be able to interact
with you regularly,
not just at events
like this, so we can
learn how to serve you better.
And it's been amazing
to see the progress
that developers in this
region have been making.
Apps and games
developed here in India
are now generating 2.5
billion downloads per month
globally on Google Play.
That's amazing.
Revenue growth from apps and
games developed here in EMEA
is accelerating.
The number of developers
grossing more than $1 million
a month through their apps--
developers based here in EMEA--
that number has grown
30% this year alone.
That's phenomenal progress.
Congratulations.
Going forward, we're
working on a lot of things
to make our platforms
more powerful and more
intelligent to help you build
better and more performant
apps, reach broader audiences,
better engage your users,
and better understand
your users.
And you'll hear a lot
about those things today.
I'm also really excited
about the innovation
that we're seeing
in devices, which
is a function of the power of
the Android platform coupled
with great work being done
by our device manufacturers.
And this innovation is
happening in targeted ways
in every segment.
We've seen some phenomenal
Android flagship
devices come out this year.
These are devices that
really are pushing
the boundaries of
technology and computing
and industrial design.
And those devices will bring
us new opportunities next year.
For example, what
will we be able to do
when devices include onboard
artificial intelligence
processing capability
or when devices include
the capability to build AR
apps to bring the real world
into your apps, and vise versa?
And in the mid-tier
segment, we've
seen manufacturers be able
to deliver premium hardware
at affordable prices,
which is going
to engage an entirely
new segment of users
in a much deeper way with apps.
And at the entry level,
we've seen innovation
in data plan pricing
and the ability
to bring very low-cost, quality
smartphones to users in markets
around the world
and make computing
more accessible than
it's ever been before.
Our own Project Go, which we
talked about at Google I/O,
is aimed at this
segment and aimed
at working on both better
devices at lower costs,
but also a set of best
practices for all of you
to reach users in these
markets and create
unique experiences for them.
I'm also excited by all
the ways that Android
is coming to more types of
devices with Android Wear
and Android Auto and
Android TV, and now
on the desktop with Android
apps available on Chromebooks.
Not only is this
creating opportunities
to build specific use
cases for these devices,
but it's also making us think
about a world in which users
have several of
these devices and are
moving across these
devices during their days.
And how can we
create experiences
that bring these
devices together
and bring these
experiences together?
All of this represents our
opportunity going forward,
and it's also going to
challenge us to keep up.
But as a community, I
think we're up to the task,
and I can't wait to see
what we all do next.
So thank you.
And with that, I'll
pass it off to Ishan
to talk about the Play Store.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ISHAN CHATTERJEE: Thanks, Jamie.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Ishan, and I focus
on Google Play's business
across apps, games, movies,
TV, and the other content
verticals in EMEA.
I am really excited to tell
you about all the changes
that we're making in
the store to make it
the best possible destination
for users to engage
with your apps and games.
Now, as Jamie said,
Play's mission
is to bring devices to
life on mobile and beyond.
So whether it's your phone,
your watch, or increasingly,
your car, Play is
the thread that
connects those 2 billion
devices to the content that
makes those devices magical.
And that's why I'm really
keen to share with you some
of the improvements that we're
making on personalization,
which is the building block of
everything that we do on Play.
And I'm also going
to talk a little bit
about the new experiences that
we're creating in the store.
So let's dive straight
in with personalization.
We have created a new
taxonomy that groups
apps and games into
hundreds of different topics
that users can engage with.
This taxonomy drives our
search filters as well as
the recommendations
on the homepage.
We also want to go
beyond the install
and focus on reengagement.
Now, you'll see a lot of changes
that we're making in the store.
But one good example
of that is the
don't forget to try cluster
that surfaces apps and games
that you've recently installed.
Now, personalization
and machine learning
are great tools to connect
up the right content
to the right user.
You heard Jamie
mention that just now.
But in the store,
we want to do more.
We want to help users decide
what content to actually
install by highlighting the
very best of the catalog.
And that's why creating
new editorial experiences
has been a big focus
area for us this year,
including rich long-form content
that you see up there which
explains why we've selected to
highlight that particular app.
These Editor's Choice
stories are now
available in 17
different countries.
In addition to that,
we're continuing
to invest in a number of
different programs that
reward and recognize our
developer partners for creating
wonderful experiences
on Android and Play,
such as the Android Excellence
Program and the Best of Play.
And in that vein, it
gives me great pleasure
to announce the launch of the
second edition of the Google
Play Indie Games
Contest and EMEA.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
This contest aims to celebrate,
to recognize, and reward
the very best of the
indie games talent
that we have in the region.
Finalists will be showcased
in the Indie Games
Corner of the Play Store.
They'll get a chance to showcase
their games at the Saatchi
Gallery in London as well as
win a number of different prizes
that will help them be
successful on Android and Play.
Now, we're really
lucky today because we
have a number of finalists
from last year's contest
in the audience with us.
So I'd like to take a
minute to actually ask
all of them to please stand up.
There we go.
Can we have a round of
applause for them, please?
[APPLAUSE]
So if any of you have questions
about what that experience was
like, please reach out to
them in the break for a chat.
All the details about
this year's contest
are at the playground,
which is right below us,
and that's where you
can sign up as well.
So please do.
Moving on from indie
games to all games.
Now, apps are different from
games, and we all know that.
So we have elevated games
to its own destination
within the store.
Not only does that drive
more users to gaming content,
it also gives us the
chance and opportunity
to create new experiences
that are unique to gaming,
such as immersive
recommendations that
include trailers or
screenshots of actual gameplay.
We also want to give users more
control of how they explore
the catalog, so
we're experimenting
with new formats in the store,
such as a section dedicated
to new games that
highlight the latest
high-quality releases on Play.
Similarly, we've
launched a new section,
a premium section
on the store, that
highlights paid games only.
And also, it
showcases content that
is on sale using our
strikethrough pricing feature.
This collection went
live last month,
and we've already seen a big
increase in engagement as well
as in purchases.
We also want to be known
as a store where gamers
can discover what's happening
on games that they already have.
So a first step to
live ops discovery
is through the use
of the Live Ops Card
that focuses on major
in-game events that
are happening now on the
games that users are currently
playing.
Now, that's a lot about games,
so now moving on to apps.
As you'll see in the
middle screenshot,
we've already started to
feature major content events
in the entertainment
category, and we're
going to be extending that to
many other categories going
forward.
And finally, I'm really
excited to announce
the launch of our
very first integration
with Android Instant Apps, which
now comes with a Try Now button
directly on the Store Listings
page that allows users
to experience some of the
functionality of the app
without actually
having to download it.
That was a really
quick whistle stop tour
through some of the changes
that we're making in the store.
And to tell you more
about some of the changes
we're making at
the Play Console,
I'd now like to
hand over to Kobi.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KOBI GLICK: Thanks, Ishan.
Hi.
I'm Kobi, a product
manager on Google Play.
The Play Console offers you
tools at every step of your app
lifecycle.
Last year, we had a
big focus on quality.
We launched Android vitals at
I/O. The Play Console is where
you release your app to users.
And we keep on iterating
our testing, targeting,
and release tools
based on your feedback.
Finally, the
console offers tools
to everyone on your team--
marketing and acquisition,
financials, customer support.
Everyone can find tools that
are helpful for what they do.
Let's start with quality.
You're probably familiar
with this slide.
50% of one-star reviews
are when users complain
about bugs or stability.
Higher-quality apps
means happier users,
which drives all your KPIs up--
revenue, retention, you name it.
It's the foundation of
your whole app success.
And what we give
you with quality
is a combination of
metrics, tools, and rewards.
For metrics, we collect
telemetry data from the field
and surface it to you
through Android vitals.
We offer you tools before,
during, and after release.
Before the release, we offer
you the pre-launch report.
And we recently added some
feature in this report,
allowing you to get it for
every alpha and beta APK
that you have.
During the release, we offer
you the Release Dashboard,
which shows you the health
of your release comparing
to previous releases.
And after the release, we
offer you Android vitals.
Finally, Google Pay rewards apps
that show exemplary behavior.
So we launched
Android vitals at I/O,
and you started
using it right away.
In the last 28 days, we've seen
65% of top developers using
Android vitals.
With vitals, everyone on your
team-- not just engineering--
can set KPIs around app quality.
And I'm happy to
announce that today,
we're launching five new bad
behaviors in Android vitals.
For example, on the
stability front,
we'll now show you sessions
when there are multiple crashes.
And on the battery
front, we will
let you know when your app
drains unnecessary power when
the user is away
from their device,
leading to unnecessary drain.
We've also revamped the
Android vitals dashboard.
To begin with,
we've significantly
increase the device coverage.
We work with OEM to add
flagship [INAUDIBLE] devices
all the way to
mid-range bestsellers
so you now have much more
data at your fingertips.
The Android vitals dashboard
itself was changed to show
your performance
overview at a glance,
including performance
over time and benchmarks .
And Android vitals plays now
a key signal in Google Play.
Our search and
discovery algorithms
favor apps with better vitals.
And when your app is considered
for promotional opportunities,
like new and updated editors
choice or Google Play Awards,
vitals play a key role.
An area that is
related to quality
and is near and dear to
our heart is security.
So I'm happy to
announce a new program--
the Google Play
Security Reward Program.
How does it work?
So firstly, we'll be reaching
out to developers like you,
asking you to opt in
and join the program.
Then we'll have friendly
security researchers
scan your app.
And if they find a
security vulnerability,
they report it to you through
your bug reporting system.
If you don't have one,
our friends from HackerOne
will be happy to help.
Then once you fix
the vulnerability,
the researcher comes back
to Google for a payout.
Then our Android security team
can scan the entire catalog,
surfacing the same vulnerability
to other developers,
helping them fix their app,
making the Android ecosystem
more secure for our users.
Together with other
security programs,
we have in Google,
Android, and Chrome,
we're happy to continue
our great relationship
with the security industry,
making the app ecosystem safer.
OK.
Let's talk about
releases now, and I
have some exciting news here.
For years, beta testing has
been one of the most popular
features on Google Play.
We have more than 300,000
developers using beta testing.
But one feature request
that always emerged
was the ability to
target apps and betas
to different countries.
And you can see
the feedback here
from our friends at Space Ape
Games telling us how badly they
wanted this feature.
So I have some great news.
Starting today, we're
launching this feature.
You'll now be able to
target your beta apps
to different countries.
Woo hoo!
[APPLAUSE]
So until today, the way it
works is that when you target
a country-- let's say Germany--
you have to target it across
alpha, beta, and production.
But starting today, you will
be able to target your app
to different countries in alpha
versus beta versus production.
So for example, you can
run a beta test in Germany
before launching it publicly.
We're sure you'll find great
ways to use this new feature.
Another feature
that you guys use
quite a lot is stage rollout.
And I have another
great announcement here.
In a few weeks, we
will start allowing
you to do country-targeted
stage rollouts.
How does it work?
You can see right here.
Let's say you have an
issue you want to isolate,
let's say, in India.
So you start by rolling
your app to 1% India only.
If everything looks
good, then you
can continue and go
to 10% in India only.
At that stage, perhaps you want
to add a control group country.
Maybe you add
Indonesia, still at 10%.
Then if everything looks
good, then you bump to 20%
and add more countries.
And finally, you finish by
rolling out to 100% globally.
Pretty cool, right?
Another feature we launched
at I/O is the device catalog.
It allows you to look at the
hardware spec of every device
supported by your app.
It became very
popular with you guys.
For example, in
the last 28 days,
we've seen 66% of top developers
engaging with the catalog.
And one thing the
catalog allows you to do
is to search for devices based
on a range of attributes--
RAM, system on chip, screen
size and density, and many more.
Starting today, we're
launching a new feature
allowing you to construct
your search queries,
save them, and reuse
them across your catalog.
So you can create a search
query like high screen devices
running on [INAUDIBLE]
and then use it
in every app in your catalog
to see the installs, rating,
and revenue driven
by those devices.
Another feature
we're launching today
comes to answer a very frequent
question we get from you guys--
why isn't this device
supporting my app?
So starting today,
you'll be able to go
to every device in the catalog,
deep dive to that device,
and see the support
stages across alpha, beta,
and production-- for
example, highlighting cases
like the one you see right
here where the device doesn't
support your app because your
app requires certain hardware
or software feature that
this device doesn't support.
Now I want to continue
and talk about how
we help you grow your business.
And I want to focus on the
fastest-growing business model
in the industry-- subscription.
You remembered it
at I/O. We shared
that the number of
subscribers and the revenue
from subscription businesses
have doubled on Google
Play in the last year alone.
And I'm going to share
with you some new features
at every step of the process--
setting up subscriptions,
acquiring new users,
and retaining them.
So let's start with setup.
We recently launched a
Play Billing Library 1.0.
And using this
library is a great way
to make sure you're using the
latest and greatest features
our billing stock has to offer.
In a few days,
we'll be launching
another big
improvement to testing.
We'll be launching a
good form of payment
and a bad form of payment
associated with every test
account.
This allows you to test both the
happy path and the unhappy path
without actually using
a real form of payment.
And in addition, we're launching
a new Subscription Management
page in the Play
Console today that
allows you to opt in into
various features related
to subscriptions.
Now, your app's success
depends on your ability
to acquire new users.
And our data shows
that 78% of users
start with a free experience.
So we're making some changes
to how free trials work
on Google Play.
To begin with, to
reduce free trial abuse,
we'll be making free trial
an app-level setting.
In addition, we've
heard your feedback
about wanting a shorter
free trial period.
So starting last
week, we now allow
you to run free trials
of minimum three days.
And user acquisition
is important.
But if you cannot retain those
users, you have a problem.
Right?
So we are here to help.
You remember that
at I/O, we announced
that we have a feature
called Account Hold that
is available on beta.
So I'm happy to announce that
starting today, this feature is
available for all of you.
All you need to do is opt in
through the New Subscription
page in the Play Console.
But the one feature I'm
really excited about
is our new feature for win back.
We will now-- starting today,
we will notify you every time
the subscription state changes,
including cancellation,
in real time.
This means that no more waiting
until the end of the month
to find out that the subscriber
churned two weeks ago.
We will now let you
know in real time,
allowing you to start to
win back process right away.
And in addition, we're enabling
another new feature today--
subscription restoration.
This feature allows
users on Play Store
to come back to your service
if they've changed their mind
without almost any friction.
So today, we shared
some exciting news.
We have new Android vitals.
We have country targeting
for alpha and beta.
And we have some
great new features
to drive the success of your
subscription businesses.
We're sure you'll use
those features to do
what you do so well--
launching such great apps
and games on Google Play.
Thank you very much for
joining, and enjoy Playtime.
[APPLAUSE]